Film Courage: What's the most broke you've been in
your life and can you tell us a story
about it? R.L. Scott, Filmmaker: Hmmm?
In regards to filmmaking? Film Courage: Yes. Just
a time in your life? R.L.: Probably when I
made my first movie, my first feature
film. I actually produced my first movie
for five hundred bucks
shot it in three weeks between my house
my neighbor's house and a friend's house
that was like around the corner so so
between like a one-block radius like I
in the way the way it happened is sort
of like I this is actually interesting
so I had prep to do my first movie it
was it was a totally different idea than
what I ended up going with I had done
pre-production for maybe two months and
it was all going to take place in like
this this really big building and the
day before we were gonna start shooting
the investor pulled out it's like Oh
something came up I can't you know I
can't do it so we'd prepped myself to
cast everybody we'd done all this prep
for two months we put like a deposit on
the location that we were going to use
the building we couldn't get the deposit
back so I think that happened on a
Saturday we were supposed to start
shooting Sunday night so I get the news
on Saturday I call up the cast between
Saturday and Sunday I spoke to everybody
I said look this is what happened and
yeah now we don't have a we don't have a
budget we don't have you know everything
we prepped for is pretty much we're at
square one now and I was like I know you
guys are ready to shoot they had already
took enough people to take enough days
and took off time to shoot
film I said look we're gonna shoot a
movie give me a day and I will give back
to you but but come and now we I guess
we we couldn't shoot Sunday so it was
gonna be Monday I said just give me a
day
come Monday we're gonna start shooting
so the way I ended up shooting my first
feature was I would write the scenes
that we were gonna shoot that day in the
morning the cast would show up that day
get the scenes we would go through the
scenes and basically we would shoot the
scene so that the same day they got the
scenes we shot them there were action
scenes in the film I would have to
choreograph the fights the day of and
teach it to the actors the day we shot
them so we basically shot the film that
way every single day like I would shoot
that day and then do the work that night
to prep coming into the morning and we
so we shot the whole movie that way
most of the actors had no martial arts
training but I actually developed now
this is also very interesting I've
developed a way of choreographing at
fight scenes over the years and making
actors look like they know how to fight
you know and I use the sword as it's
like this chain chain length method
where you take three or four techniques
we call it an exchange right so one
exchange would be through four
techniques you teach those three or four
techniques to the actors it's sort of a
short a short burst of energy versus
like just shooting a fight full-on and
people getting tired and then that's how
accidents happened right but you could
get a short burst of energy out of them
for three or four techniques and and
then the Edit you use the last technique
of that exchange you would use that to
cut into
the first technique of the next exchange
and I actually learned that method from
looking at like when I was young you
know the barrel of monkeys where they
would have the hands that would connect
and you pull them out of the theatre of
the barrel of monkeys so that's how I
learned to to choreograph and then cut
the way I would cut is I would use the
last part of datak stage as the first
move so even though you're shooting
these tiny little bursts of action when
you cut them together they seem seamless
because you always use the material from
the last punch
so I guess to simplify that if if I have
an exchange and the last the last
technique you've met exchanges a
straight punch right the next technique
in the new exchange is that same
straight punch you know that me so that
you're able to carry that over and that
I'm using the straight punch from the
second exchange not the last technique
of that exchange so that way it just
seems like a constant stream of energy
like this non-stop sort of action
sequence even though it was like these
really tiny bursts so that way you can
keep everybody safe and you can sort of
control how you know how things are done
and then you you you you use composition
based on like what's going to make that
technique look the best so you're able
to hide their flaws and and sort of show
their strengths hi their weaknesses that
sort of thing but um but yeah I think
that whole three weeks of making my
first feature with I had no script I had
no you know I had to write it as we shot
and they had no prep we had no money you
know that's probably like the brokest
I've been but that but that movie got
like worldwide distribution and it's
sort of yeah that also showed me like
how much power you really have like as a
content creator like how you can sort of
create something and even if it's in a
rough situation it can it can still do
great things and it can still be
received well and yeah that just opened
up a world of possibilities after that
and then how confident did that make you
going forward before every other shoot
because you basically had the bottom
fall out yeah and you still made it work
somehow I mean you had people that it
could have been very mad it took all
this time off whatever everybody was
probably like heartbroken you made it
work somehow
how does that build your confidence yeah
I mean it it was great because I'm I
never I never gave them the impression
that things were just you know what I
mean I was very calm you know this
happened but this is what we're gonna do
you know like I never I never made it
feel like it was a problem like just
this thing that we couldn't get past or
you know I just I don't know is this the
way I delivered it to him I guess and
then I think also because they had seen
a lot of the other work I'd done like
the shorts and stuff like that
I think they were pretty confident that
like you know we'd be okay but I was
very much I was never like oh my god
they did this and I don't know what
we're gonna you know I never never did
that I was just like hey you know we're
gonna just change gears a little bit you
know this is what happened we're still
making a film yeah so I think just being
calm and never sort of letting on how
crazy things have gotten I think I think
that helped a lot and to have it go so
wrong and to be able to come
the other side was something that was
like tangible like yeah that changed
everything for me like you know I just
didn't feel like it was that I didn't
feel like it was anything I couldn't do
at that point I just felt like you just
find a way like you stay calm you figure
it out
you problem-solve and because if you
strip away all the essentials right when
you get down to what the film really is
its location its actors you know
lighting sound you know composition
storytelling you know and whether it's
100 million dollars or $100 you can
still tell a story if you have the tools
and you know you can you can still tell
a great story it's it really isn't about
the money at all money helps money can
make things grander or bigger or
whatever but when it really comes down
to telling like a human story it you
really don't need a lot to do that you
know and yeah that's what it taught I'm
sure it wasn't
excellent at the time but yeah that's
really scary yeah I just didn't I really
didn't panic just because I was so used
to it I was so used to making these
things like the way I was making them
you know like as a kid like I was so
used to just okay I'm gonna write in my
shit I'm gonna I'm gonna you know we're
gonna use this room or that room like so
to me it felt like just going back to
like how I started you know and I was
comfortable in that and I think that's
the reason why I didn't see a reason to
panic I just was like okay we can't do
that but we can do this yeah yeah
you